hey everyone
welcome to this live
session brought to you by the world
science festival and in fact
those of you who have
been avidly watching some of the
sessions that we have
been putting out to the world over the
last whatever 16 18 months or so
will note that my background is a little
bit different from what it normally has
been for the most part i have been
coming to you from
our home in upstate new york where we
had the bucolic rolling fields of green
or
snowy plains behind me as the seasons
change now as you look behind me
you see that we have a
somewhat different a different view this
is the view of manhattan i'm
on the 19th floor of
the interchurch center in uptown
manhattan which is the
headquarters of the world science
festival
so this will be our background from time
to time as we begin to migrate
back we hope to ordinary normal life
who the heck knows so with uh
everything that's going on in the world
but we'll press forward and look we'll
find
all of us will find our
way now some of you may know that about
two weeks ago and in fact not about
exactly two weeks ago we posted the
first of our
programs created in a virtual
environment since we can't have our
usual live programs in front of a live
audience at least not yet maybe sometime
in the not too distant future that will
be possible again and that was a program
called
does math reveal
reality where we had a
interesting conversation with a variety
of perspectives on
what mathematics is
whether mathematics and reality are
somehow
the same or whether math is just a
description of reality whether math is
real whether it's something concocted by
the human mind the human brain
excuse me
so that was an interesting
conversation now
in that a number of you raised questions
and indeed
inspired by your questions because we do
listen to what you guys say
in the comments
so long as it's positive we tend not to
listen to the negative ones no we do
that's that's facetious we listen and we
read all of the comments but a number of
you wanted to hear more about one
particular perspective that was
articulated by max tegmark in that
conversation so indeed that is what
we're going to do today but first let me
just give a quick
advertisement for the next of our
programs in that virtual theater the
virtual space and that will be a program
i'm not exactly sure what we're going to
call it but it's a program on on
language
and the nature of language where
language comes from and why we speak and
the role that language has in shaping
the kinds of things that we're able to
think about
and whether or not language is the
substrate of thought or whether language
is
a tool of human communication
participants in that program you sort of
couldn't have a better group to debate
and discuss
these issues noam chomsky right i mean
noam chomsky
the grand master of language and master
of many other disciplines as well was
part of that program stephen pinker
again many of you know him from his many
books on language and thought
more recently focused on other issues
the level of
violence in human societies across time
that have really
sparked a lot of interest a lot of
discussion we also spoke with evelina
federenco
and daniel dorr
scientists who have been investigating
the nature of language both from
anthropological sociological but also
from a neurological stance
examining
mri and fmri images of the brain when
it's undertaking various tasks some
language related some not and seeing
parts of the brain that
light up and talk to each other when
these kinds of activities are
being undertaken inside of the head that
program is going to be released i
believe on september 16th
so keep an eye out for
that program and that rhythm two weeks
ago
does math reveal reality now this
conversation that we'll have in a moment
with max tag mark in two weeks from now
the language program that will be partly
our rhythm but our goal don't hold me to
it immediately because it's in process
gearing up but our goal is to have
weekly programming not not every other
week i never know if that's bi-weekly or
semi-weekly perhaps we should have
investigated that in the language
program but no doubt in the chat
somebody will tell me which of those is
the correct phraseology but in any event
we hope to be weekly but for the time
being it'll be
every other week so tune in for all of
that programming going forward and i can
quickly say i believe that after the
language program we'll have a cosmology
program a discussion with
alan guth andre linde and we'll probably
follow that up with
a related cosmology program that will
give alternative perspectives to the
viewpoint that guth and linday will
espouse in
that upcoming conversation one quick
thing i'll
mention or
encourage you to provide thoughts on
this language program i mentioned i'm
not sure what we're going to call it
we're thinking of it as language and
thought but if any of you guys have a
more catchy title for a program that
investigates the origin of language and
why we speak and the role that language
has in human thought human cognition
give us your title
we'd be more than happy to give you
credit where credit is due but give us a
catchy title if anything comes to mind
for
that language program that is upcoming
okay with that little preamble
let's now turn to the main part of this
live session
which is a conversation with my friend
and colleague max tegmark who i believe
is already
with us i see him there in the waiting
room so
i will
alert the folks here behind the scenes
to bring max there he is
max how are you doing so great to see
you again brian
virtually yeah exactly and thanks uh
thanks for taking a little time to uh
discuss things with us here today i mean
people
were quite
um
enthralled
uh angered
uh
agitated
uh interested by the conversation that
we had a little while back
that we
put out to the world two weeks ago and
as i mentioned in
in my introductory remarks
your position your position is one that
people really wanted to uh
investigate a little bit further and
that's what i'd like to do today but
before getting there if you don't mind
just a little background
on on on who you are where you came from
it's always good to frame the
conversation so it's always you know
it's always mystifying to to you know
tracy who you know my wife that we
physicists know so little about each
other from the personal perspective i
knew that you i know that you grew up at
least in part in sweden in stockholm
but i don't know much more about your
your early background than that so give
us a a quick sketch of of young max
tegmark yeah so i was
born in uh i did kindergarten through
college and
mostly in
stockholm sweden and
i discovered as i was lying in my
hammock that i had put up between two
apple trees you know as a teenager that
i just loved big questions
and and the bigger they were
the more on fire i would get about them
and um
so it was pretty natural that i
gravitated
towards
them and when i came to grad school i
you know i fell in love with travel as a
teenager and i thought hmm if i'm gonna
spend any more time in school why don't
why not combine it with some cool travel
and i felt so lucky when i
got admitted to go to california do grad
school in a different country
pack my bags and then i saw a poster in
the elevator once at uc berkeley saying
there was a course in cosmology and
hadn't even dawned upon me that there
was such a subject before i immediately
thought wow
what bigger questions can there be than
about the cosmos so i signed up for it
and and joe silk who thought that course
ended up being my my thesis advisor
and many of the conversations that you
and i have had over the years of course
have had to do with these great
questions about our universe and its
origins and how big is it and
and is that all there is
but that's not the only big question in
fact back when i was in in that hammock
between the apple trees is that in a
metaphorical hammock or no
and it was the real hammock between two
apple trees the cloth had deteriorated
enough that the other year when i put it
up again it actually actually fell
through it but my industrious
version of newton in the apple right
niece sally put up a new one a more
modern fabric and i was lying in it
actually just recently
and i used to think back then that um
the two biggest questions actually were
about our universe out there
and a universe in here
and
we will be talking i think a fair bit of
that also when we talk about the nature
of mathematics and whether it's invented
out here and whether it's out there and
whether math also can describe not just
the motion of planets but also
mental
things like intelligence and
consciousness and and throughout my
career just to wrap up the answer to
your question you can see the first
25 years or so i spent very much going
on this outward journey
and in the last five years i've really
shifted my research on this inward
journey my research at mit with my group
now for the past five years on
artificial intelligence mostly
and
another area where mathematics
has proven able to
conquer new ground in science yeah
things which we used to think were
beyond mathematical description and now
we can do it in our in our computers now
we'll we'll move on in just a moment i'm
just wondering as a kid were you a math
kid i mean was math your thing or was
that something you came to later on
i
liked math uh i i thought it's fun but
but um
uh didn't do much with anything
particularly with my my my late father
math professor so i feel the love for
math from him and and later on uh i had
many many fascinating conversations
about him not not so much about how to
solve equations but about how did he
think about what math even is and
that certainly influenced me a lot but i
i had a
very um
trajectory through academics like my
undergrad was an economics you know go
figure oh gosh i didn't know that yeah
and there are just so many interesting
things you can think about right and now
you have a professor salary got your
econ friends to be like what did you do
max god what a mistake that was it's
crazy and then i get to spend all my day
thinking about
whatever interesting things they want
then that they even
pay me for it it's quite scandalous yeah
right now that side of it is utterly
astounding yeah so anyone listening to
this wondering about whether they should
go into academia or not
i highly recommend it yeah yeah well i
can't say that i have any other view
than that the freedom of
life and thought that comes from the
academic life is uh second to none but
anyway let's turn now to um
some of the issues that came up in our
previous conversation and uh
let's not assume that people watched the
previous program although i encourage
everybody who's watching this to to take
a look at math and reality as it really
did cover a lot of ground
but i think it's fair to say that you
and i
while we see eye to eye i think on many
things just from the conversations we've
had over decades i think there's a lot
of alignment between us
i think when it comes to mathematics we
we have
radically different views um and i
should preface that by saying
there was a time when i think my view is
much closer to yours that that math is
just out there
and we discover it and so forth and i
think for me i mean you discussed how
the last five years you've sort of had a
bit of a shift in your focus i've
certainly had a shift in my thinking
about things over the last five ten
years which has led me to a different
view but we'll come to that let's let's
begin with your perspective so when you
think of
mathematics you think of it as much more
than a human description of the external
world so perhaps give people a flavor
for where you see
mathematics fitting into
the ontology the real stuff of reality
yeah so i like how you describe there's
this being a spectrum
so if this is the spectrum of views you
can have on the nature of math right
then one extreme is to be here and say
well math is just all in your head it's
something we've invented it has very
little to do with the physical world
i'm going to be defending exactly
opposite extreme case it sounds like
you've kind of moved maybe from here
brian when i last spoke to you to hear
yeah i'm not very interested in hearing
the arguments that drove you there i
when you
look at the bigger picture it's this is
not the new idea obviously and
already
over 2 000 years ago the pythagoreans
were talking about how
there was something special about math
and galileo you know famously about 400
years ago said that our universe is a
grand book you know written in the in
the language of math so he was already
pretty far over on this side
before we go any further i think it's
worth just that we clarify for for our
viewers here what
he even meant about this because when
you look around the world like what are
you what skelete are you even talking
about i look behind you i see clouds you
know like
i don't see any numbers written there
except it says live 16 colon 2 2. that's
mathematical but that was put by humans
no what is there actually in the world
behind you that's that has mathematical
properties and
it's really not evident at first except
when you start looking
through the eyes of a physicist because
then what i see when i look at you brian
is a blob of quarks and electrons no
offense
that's a compliment you take that as a
compliment okay and if i look at you
know your electrons like what what
properties do they have
you know that your electrons have the
properties minus one one half
one and so on and you also know that we
physics nerds have fancy names for those
properties like electric charge
spin and lepton number but we made up
those names
what they call them the properties of
electrons are just the numbers
and as far as we can tell the only
difference between your electrons brian
and your up quarks and your down quarks
are
what numbers those properties are right
and
when the space i see you sitting in
there you know
that all those particles are in
what properties does the space have
well
three for example because that's the
largest number of fingers you can put
that are all uh perpendicular to one
another right yep
and again we humans invented in our
language a word for that we call it the
dimensionality of space and we measure
it and it's three
but the property itself is just the
number
and then einstein came along and said
well there's some more probabilities of
space also topology and curvature which
you know we study in math class because
they're also just
mathematical so if you take seriously
that all the properties we've discovered
that the stuff in space has and the
space itself has are all mathematical it
starts to sound a bit less ridiculous
the idea that maybe it's actually
universe has only mathematical
properties that's the position
that i'm going to be defending here
so along those lines though
and um i think it's a kind of an issue
that we need to
chip away at
somewhat slowly because it is what
you're describing is is is for some
certainly for me
uh
a different world view right um and that
is curious for me to say because i'm
fully on board when we talk about a
mathematical description of the
particles
you know i teach my students and you
teach your students you know we stand up
there we teach quantum mechanics and
quantum field theory
and it's certainly the case that when
we're doing that
we describe the particles using the
minus one for the electric charge and
then we talk about electromagnetism
using even more fancy mathematics that
some of our listeners may be familiar
with you know a u1 gauge theory right
now all of this is is is mathematical
structure with the ingredients
fully described by the numerical values
that you made reference to charge spin
and and so on and so forth but
for me and i think for some many perhaps
what we are talking about
is a description of those particles yeah
as opposed to
the particles themselves and that may
sound like a fine distinction but
obviously we know it's a kind of huge
distinction so to
to
articulate the issue in a nugget
doesn't the electron have one other
property that those numbers don't quite
capture which is existence
right it isn't just the possibility of a
particle with charge negative one and
you know spin a half and so forth
it's a particle that exists in the real
world
that has those properties so so don't
you need more than just the mathematics
to go beyond
abstract possibility to
real existence that's such a great
question so let me let me say two things
about that first of all
when you teach your quantum field theory
course right at columbia then you don't
just teach them that the electron is a
particle you actually say that the real
thing that exists is rather this thing
called the electron positron field and
there is also something mathematical
there a number called the occupation
number that tells you how many electrons
there are in each momentum state right
so now whether the electron exists or
not just comes down to whether there is
a zero or one in a certain place
so i think it's not the existence so
much that's at the rub of this but
there's another question that just you
hit out there which is really core and i
i think of it as
being a little bit related to how humble
we are as humans
if you take for example um
you know my my dad passed away earlier
this year so i'll pay tribute to him by
by telling you something very cute he
asked me once when i was a kid he said
max jupiter
how do we know that it's called jupiter
this planet and we haven't been there i
might have been five years old or
something i went away thinking about
this for a long time he had this
wonderful
strategy of asking of me questions he
knew the answer to
but letting me think and
if you ask me you know did we invent
jupiter or did we discover it right i
think it would be really arrogant if we
claim that we in that we invented it
jupiter was clearly out there for us to
discover right
and
why
why is that well it's we we feel that
way because jupiter has additional
properties
there's there's
beyond those that we have discovered
already and catalogued and so on there's
but let's contrast that with something
with us playing suppose there is some
super advanced computer game in the
future
because ai keeps progressing and it's so
good that some of the characters in this
computer game are
can have the kind of conversation with
each other that you and i can have and
they'll feel conscious and aware and so
on and one of them looks through their
virtual telescope
and discovers a new planet in the
computer game uh and then they start
discussing well did we discover this
planet or did we invent it and
one of them says well you know we we
just discovered it because it exists
out there you know
to you and me though this whole computer
game is just a bunch of zeros and ones
yeah and in some sense
it's that planet isn't any more real
than any other math in this thing and
and the uncanny feeling i have been
getting the more physics i've done over
the years is
that the we keep discovering that our
reality is more and more like this kind
of computer game world where we look at
things
where we were pretty convinced that
there was more to it than just the math
mathematical properties and then
eventually all the other stuff sort of
milled away like we we look at the
we look at the jupiter and we realize we
can describe the whole the whole thing
seems to be made of electrons and quarks
in some certain arrangement
we then we thought well what about the
fact that brian greene is talking to me
right now and being very intelligent
surely
that
must mean that there are some other
properties of brian that can't be
described with math
but now artificial intelligence research
is even challenging that right it's it's
it's not at all obvious that you need
anything beyond
the
list
so that i i i fully agree with but if we
don't leave your simulation example
quite so quickly i'm just wondering so
if i go into a virtual reality
experience
and in that virtual world which is very
much like your simulation but at least
it's one that you can actually do right
now and in there
if i go through
and and take my virtual reality
telescope and i'm looking at jupiter
right jupiter of course is just zeros
and ones in some elaborate computer
program that's creating this right
simulation of but that jupiter is not
real
as the real jupiter is like you wouldn't
want to conflate those two ideas even
though each has a mathematical
description right the mathematical
description of jupiter in the virtual
world is responsible for my experience
in that headset
the mathematical description of jupiter
in the real world allows us to
articulate the trajectory of jupiter and
its reflectivity and all that sort of
stuff but wouldn't you want to draw a
distinction between them
that must somehow go beyond the
mathematical representation because
they're not an equal footing or or are
they well
if we know that we made that super
intelligent computer game then and are
looking at it from outside we know of
course that they're not on an equal
footing
we know for sure that that virtual brian
green is zeros and ones but
the first question we should ask is does
that does he know that right does
virtual brian realize that he's a
simulation
it's not so obvious to him right if we
program in laws of physics there are the
same as in this world he's going to
touch himself and he's going to feel
this feels really real and if if someone
slaps you you know it's going to feel
very real and and and then if that
virtual brian starts to study the laws
of physics and discovers you know the
standard model of particle physics uh
he's in the same epistemological yeah
logical situation that you are so it's
not so easy for someone inside right
and and
what i'm saying is
we find ourselves in a situation like
this that so far i would argue
and this is a controversial thing i'm
saying which you should feel free to
push back on but i would argue that so
far
we have found no phenomena at all in
science where we're convinced
that
that we can that
they cannot ultimately be described with
the tools of of science you know physics
and math
and some people would disagree and say
maybe consciousness is different or
or maybe something else but i think it's
up in the air but i think we're on the
same page regarding i don't expect us to
hit a wall so one day
suppose that's true that there is no
roadblock and that all the phenomena we
observe around us can ultimately be
described with mathematical equations
and you know maybe they're even elegant
enough that one day you can have a
t-shirt that you can give away to people
at the world science festival that have
them on it you know
then where does this leave that leave us
right uh does it mean that we're
simulated and that the simulators
decided that these were the equations
they were going to put into the super
computer because that was the most
important interesting and fun game they
could make you know some people think
that and and write papers about it
or
is it the case that you don't even have
to simulate it
so
that's where i got really really
interested in you know if you if you
talk to
physicists we are physicists right
when we ask questions about what exists
or not you know we very much start with
the kind of stuff we can touch and and
kind of build on that but when i talk
with uh
for example my my colleague david vogen
at mit he's a mathematician right he has
a huge poster in his office
of this
10 dimensional league group he spent
like in this league group he spent like
10 years mapping out this mathematical
object he loves it that's his it's like
his baby
he feels that that exists you know
just as much as he feels that i exist
and um
see i would say it exists
in his head
and it can ex exist in other heads and
can exist in papers and in textbooks
but i don't know what it means to say
that it exists
beyond that and i know again that's a
controversial
nominalist perspective on things but
you know perhaps it's worthwhile you you
noted you noted that your view yeah
comes from a place of humility to
somebody yeah
and i feel like mine does too so let me
just let me just tell you where we're
it's a different kind of humility so my
view and this is the reason why my view
has changed uh over the years i've begun
over the last i don't know decade to
have a clearer
and more consistent maybe that's a
better way of saying it or more
consistent to my mind world view where i
look at the continuum of processes that
starts from the big bang
to the existence of stars and planets
galaxies one planet certain macro
molecules that evolve over time
evolution by natural selection they
become a more complex form and that more
complex form somehow begins to have
self-awareness again we don't really
know where that comes from but i assume
it is just physics in some way shape or
form let's just go everything you said
except the word just okay good good good
let me take that out
on it good it's not essential to
anything i'm talking about here so it is
very cool it is physics happening
exactly so so so the humility that i get
from that perspective is
when you look at things in that you
recognize that we complex collections of
molecules who are
granted through physics this
self-awareness ability to look out at
the world we try to describe the world
and to understand the world and and we
invent natural languages in order to
communicate with each other better and
then we invent mathematical languages i
don't have a temporal quality here but
mathematical languages are invented
because they have a more precise
capacity yes to articulate the patterns
but it's all happening because we
conscious beings are trying to give a
coherent description yes of the external
world and we are just the same
quarks and atoms and so forth that
everything else is made up with the one
ability beyond a rock or a chair that we
can come up with these descriptions and
the mathematical description is the one
that we come up with and so the math
comes from our heads
it's spectacular that it is able to give
us such a precise description of the
external world
but to think that we somehow are tapping
into something that is uh the deeper
level of reality that to me is is hubris
right the human reality the humility of
recognizing that all we are doing is
giving a description of the world seems
to me a a more consistent coherent
picture and one that's more humble
i love this yeah i can
i think there's a you can
i love one of the reasons i like you so
much is your humility and i think
humility can also bring you to the other
direction side of this frankly because
um
we both agree i think we must not
conflate
the description
the language of mathematics with which
we describe which is a description of
things with what is described right and
um
we've
we should probably say a few words about
what we even mean by mathematics right
in other words
we talk about whether
we live in whether the universe is math
or not so that's changed a lot in
history right it used to be that math
was just this cookbook of tricks from
multiplying numbers and you know my mom
used to view it basic mathematics
basically as a sadistic
from a torture that they use to make
kids feel bad in school
but if you talk to
modern mathematicians today
right they think of mathematics
very very differently as simply as a as
a study an exploration this study
different mathematical structures that
are out there like the one david vogen
had on his wall and for example plato
right over 2 000 years ago
was very interested in what kind of
regular three-dimensional shapes can you
make with beta polygons are all the same
and he
realized that there are five of them the
tetrahedron the cube the icosahedron the
dodecahedron
and the octahedron and
then he went off and also speculated
that that's what the four or five
elements were made of and he didn't get
chemistry quite right but
but the thing is
so you can ask did he discover or invent
the dodecahedron i would say i would
claim he actually discovered that there
were five of them he could
even if he wanted to he couldn't make
there be a sixth platonic solid
there just isn't one right wouldn't you
i don't mean to interrupt but wouldn't
you say that he
deduced it from a certain set of
assumptions a three-dimensional world
you know
the rules of mathematics and so on and
so he deduces it from those assumptions
and that deduction to me is a process of
invention
as opposed to a process of it it's out
there and i just sort of
pulled the curtain back and there's the
joe decahedron well if you it would be
so cool if we could get plato on this
show and see if he's coming in just a
lot about sitting in this cave and
imagining that there was this reality
out there that he was
discovering right and
and and his platonic realm i think he
envisioned that you know there are
certain mathematical structures that
exist and some that don't and he was in
the process of
figuring that out and the key point i
wanted to make was
regardless of what you call this process
right no matter how much he wanted
he had the freedom to call the
dodecahedron the schmodekahedron or
something else because that was the
language we invent the language and we
can call the things whatever we want but
he didn't have the freedom
to just make up a sixth one that doesn't
exist and the way
so one one question i think is really
good test for whether it makes sense to
say that something exists or not
is i think you should only say that
something exists if it's logically
possible for it to not exist like brian
green exists in that you can imagine a
world it would be a sad world where
brian green doesn't exist right thank
you
but i cannot imagine a
world where there are only where there
are only four platonic solids and the
dotica heater just ain't there does that
make sense it does make sense but i
guess i would
perhaps challenge
your criterion for
existence so your criterion for
existence is to be able to establish
logically that
the ingredient that you're talking about
could not not be there and but i would
say
i would be more convinced that something
exists
if if you gave me one and the fact of
the matter is there isn't a dodecahedron
in the real universe
there are close approximations yeah
dodecahedron in the real by real
universe i mean i could like touch and
have some causal interaction with shine
light on it see it through reflection
and have it in my hands so it doesn't
even exist in the in the right now max
doesn't need mix i don't even see it
looking like really and i used to have
behind me here as well you do okay you
know so so whatever you show me is going
to be a close approximation
but i would say all this is happening in
the mind because the things that we're
talking about they don't even exist
but i think that's let me push back on
that being a bit too hubristic because
you know space is the big place you're
going to have alan guth and andre linde
on here and a couple of weeks telling
you that space is bigger than the part
we can see right yep i even have on my
t-shirt the
some multiverses here so suppose there
is a there is another brian you know
brian green the second and he just
happens to live 50 billion light years
away
on a planet that looks a lot like earth
no there are things over there that we
can never observe
who are we to be so arrogant to say that
that stuff doesn't exist just because we
can't observe it right it's in in our
same space you know the humble thing to
do to me would be to say well if you can
touch it
brian green ii and feels it exists and
he is just as smart as you are
yeah i'll grant him that that's also
real so i don't want to limit existence
to just things that we can physically
but when you say that if if that distant
location is governed by the same laws of
physics
and has the same ingredients and any
conclusion we draw
here is reasonable to power i agree it's
a guess that it would hold over there
too so i would be pretty shocked
if if that other
max or brian could actually say no no
here's a here's a real perfect
dodecahedron exactly as the mathematical
description
articulates yeah but what if what if
there is a particular artifact that he
has succeeded in building and nobody in
our universe has managed to make right
yeah then we would say it doesn't exist
then he were like hold on here it is
yeah i i agree i agree i agree
i agree in principle but
i i guess i have maybe a more
flat-footed notion of existence where i
want to have
some interaction that at least is in
principle possible with the thing whose
existence i'm going to claim to be
really
aren't you saying then that you're going
to deny the existence of his
beautiful dodecahedron that he spent 20
years building because you can't even in
principle interact with it because it's
50 billion light years away yeah um uh i
i i get the point but i don't find it
convincing because
it's making use of a oblique quality
that the object is just too far away for
me to have a causal engagement with it
and misrepresenting you okay are you
saying that you're denying it
you won't agree that it exists for that
reason or that you're willing to concede
that it exists i'm willing to concede in
the existence of things that are too far
away for me
you know so so that that's not something
because i i full well
recognize you know from all our
discussions of cosmology that it's quite
possible and quite likely in fact that
space goes on far beyond the observable
part of the universe and i'm not going
to say that a star that's beyond the
cosmic horizon doesn't exist because i
can't see it that that's not a position
i'd be willing to take well but then it
seems like you've softened your your
position
that i thought you had a few minutes ago
that you're only going to say that
things exist if you can actually touch
them or interact with them or observe
them right yeah but i really mean there
is an in principle version of that and
so you know if i was to be transported
beyond our
cosmic horizon i could see that star and
so forth i don't think that there's any
space-time
event where i could be located where i'm
actually going to see you know a perfect
cube or
now you're going to say to me how do you
know that that's an experimental
question and and i agree that it is an
experimental question but
i can't even envision it happening in
our observable universe and since i
can't even envision it even in principle
happening
then i'm less convinced that simply by
transporting myself you know a billion
light years from here all of a sudden
it's going to be an experience i can
have to interact with this dodecahedron
okay so but did you i hope i conveyed
how i i view the opposite uh storyboard
there's also more humble because i think
the austro the proverbial ostrich and i
think that's an urban legend actually
that they stick their head in the sand
and claim that nothing exists at the
company but you've heard the legend uh
that would be very arrogant yeah the
opposite of humble to say if i can't
observe it
for sure exist and i think we've made
that mistake as a species actually many
times right assuming that everything we
knew of was everything that existed just
to realize that actually we live on this
gigantic
sphere here that's 40 000 kilometers
around and oops in this huge solar
system
in this huge galaxy and a cluster of
galaxies etc and our universe and maybe
more and i you know alan guth and andre
linde you're undoubtedly going to chat
with them two weeks from now also about
how
this level one multiverse is probably
not all there is it's just even more
diversity in our space even in our own
space time where there are other regions
where maybe space even has a different
number of dimensions and you couldn't
live because the number of quarks are
different and
and
so then i think we
have to
have a much broader
we can we have to be much more open
and humble about what things we're going
to grant existence to but will you grant
existence to something that is
permanently beyond the capacity to have
a causal interaction with us human
beings even in principle because i think
you know the traditional platonic realm
where say the perfect shapes the perfect
square
the normal
not normal but the view that i've often
heard articulated is that is a place
that exists but it's not a place that
even in principle we could have a causal
interaction with because it's beyond
space time whatever space time or it
could be yeah so since i've been picking
on you here let me make myself
vulnerable and stake out a position that
you can attack then because this is the
perfect segue to this
so
you just mentioned space time right
where is space time
exactly it well
what einstein said right was not that uh
there is a certain place you go beyond a
little bit beyond neptune and then to
the left and that's where you find space
time you had to say well we're in space
time
the position
that i'm ar that i argue for example in
in
that subversive uh book i wrote on the
topic is
rather that if you take as a starting
point that there are these mathematical
structures that have mathematical
existence
like the perfect odecahedron the perfect
cube
some columbia
et
manifold
et cetera mathematicians basically make
a living out of discovering different
kind different mathematical structures
that correspond to different axiom
systems and so on and they've cataloged
ever more complicated ones and today
they even use computers sometimes to
catalog you know new ones if you were to
grant existence
to those you can call it for now just
mathematical existence to not conflate
it with the kind you're comfortable with
okay and now you ask the question
um
suppose one
one of those mathematical structures
that you've granted mathematical
existence to
actually describes
the equations that
this the same exactly is described by
the exact same equations that we think
describe our physical world what's it
going to be like there there's a then
presumably there are people in there and
what are they going to experience their
life as
i would posit that
that the brian green is that in there is
going to feel
subjectively exactly the way you feel
so that this mathematical existence
implies
subjectively to its inhabitants uh
brian green existence that you think is
bona fide a okay you know physical
existence right and in that case who am
i to come to that brian green and be
arrogant to him and say well you don't
actually exist sorry you just feel that
you do you know
right um and um
i think it's
look part part of the uh the subtext
here is to what extent do
we
equate
the feeling of something being real
with something actually being real which
of course takes us to the whole question
of consciousness because
um but before we go there i just want to
make sure i fully understand
your your perspective because we've sort
of hinted at it but it hasn't been put
out fully on the table if i understand
again i should i should probably mention
to the audience a lot of what we're
talking about here is in max's book
which is actually we borrowed the title
for the title of this session our
mathematical universe so it's a great
read so if anyone want to go a little
bit deeper uh max's book is a place to
go but in that book
you stake out the position that that
we're sort of been walking the periphery
of which is
any mathematical object
exists
perhaps in a way that is outside of the
observable universe that we are aware of
so it's a kind of multiverse of a very
extreme variety
where any mathematical entity
has
an existence in this larger landscape
this larger multiverse of reality is
that a an accurate representation of of
the view that this perspective takes you
to
so if you if you um
take this rather modern view of
mathematics that that it's about mapping
out
these mathematical structures right then
mathematicians have actually a very nice
definition of what they mean for
something to exist mathematically
hilbert
said it most succinctly that it's
freedom from contradiction
you know if you have the axioms that you
put in
ultimately contradictory the thing goes
poof and there's
nothing there and it's remarkably hard
actually
to come up with a system of axioms that
is consistent and actually describes
something that mathematicians would
consider it to exist and that's why
that mathematicians get so excited when
they discover like a new
lead group or a new columbia manifold
that they can
can study
and um
it's it seems to me
that
everything we've seen in the history of
science so far is consistent with
the hypothesis that we live in one of
those mathematical objects and what we
call physics
theory physics equations are just
discoveries of ever more accurate
approximations of the properties of this
thing that we actually live in you know
we were first we got all excited about
newton's gravity
which clearly it was an approximation
then einstein gave us a better
approximation but we know that can't
quite be right either with general
relativity
we still don't have the exact
description mathematically of where we
think we live in
but if we did we would have a theory of
quantum gravity um but um
this is this is my guess is the what's
what's actually happening that it's
we're not um discovering physics
approximating
mathematics we're discovering
mathematics approximating the true
mathematical properties of of what we
inhabit
and
we didn't it's
if you think about it this way
i know it's very counter-intuitive and
and
you've articulated better than
than
virtually anyone else also how
complicated the whole time issue is in
this right because when you talk about
something existing you often think about
it first not existing and then poof you
know you create it
um
but
you can't create space time
there isn't the idea that
there is first no space time and then
later in time there is poof rather
space time has time in it already the
whole future and past it's all there and
you know just either the whole thing
just exists or it doesn't there's no no
creation involved and
stephen hawking has this famous quote
what is it that breathes life into
equations yes makes something exist that
for them to describe i think
that priest
said that's a wrong way of looking at it
presumably yeah i mean what do you mean
make make space time exist as if you can
create
time itself right um
in plate in this in this mathematical
landscape
you have to be very humble and realize
that there are mathematical structures
that are so different from the one we
think we live in they did some of them
don't even have time there's no time in
the dodecahedron
what's it like to live there um probably
very boring it's too simple i'm pretty
sure there's no self-awareness going on
in the dodecahedron right at people one
corner talking to another no
sure but you are saying if i go across
the street to colombia and i go to the
math library and i pull any volume off
the shelf go to a random page and
there's some equation on that page that
equation in your view exists as much as
like this cup exists it it has the same
level and same claim if i
anthropomorphize unnecessarily to
existence as anything else does is that
fairly accurate
sort of the the uh can i show you it's
like a very very yeah sure yeah yeah
dirty picture to just i i never feel i
can understand anything unless i can
make uh
unless i can somehow visualize it sure
yeah yeah i just want to show you uh
do we the means of bringing up an image
uh yeah we do either
knock on wood so i'm just gonna share my
screen here very very briefly so
here
we have a little picture that i want to
show you and uh
so
here
a little picture yes yeah i i made this
back when i i remember that coming out
just a little map of this of plato's
landscape
mathematical things so
you know mathematicians have discovered
these
things that i've drawn as little blocks
here
that they call mathematical structures
yeah the integers
here's an o
or
the natural numbers is probably the one
most of our viewers have heard about the
mathematical structure consists of
zero one two three four and so on and it
has all sorts of properties that you can
study and the plus and times and prove
difficult theorems about and so on
it's a different structure though from
for example
the real numbers
or
metric spaces or semi groups or whatever
and and over time
mathematicians have
start discovered more and more of these
boxes that are interesting and they can
prove things about them and discover
their properties
and
now some people think it's if you if you
grant it to the mathematicians that they
haven't screwed up okay and then there
are all these
mathematical structures that exist in
this mathematical sense that they that
they're not inconsistent now one one
theory is well
one of them is special
different from all the others because
god or the cosmic simulator or someone
you know went up to it and and puts the
magic smoke in and made it exist also
for real
maybe it's uh
something related to what we
we could describe string theory up here
or whatever right and then poof
now that's also real so that people
who live in there will feel that they're
in a real space and all the others are
just illusory they're just figments of
the mathematician's imagination
um
that's a tenable position i think some
people have and that i think is the
motivation of stephen hawking's question
you know what was it that breathed fire
into our equations and made a universe
for them to describe
um so john wheeler a
huge hero of mine right um
he really didn't like that
very much he felt so sort of arrogant
that we should think that just our stuff
exists somehow and it felt that we
needed to have some answer to this
question about what was so special about
ours
and
what i think we've seen again and again
on a smaller scale
was that there wasn't anything so
special about earth there are also other
planets yeah or our galaxy they're also
others
and so my guess is that it's the same
exact thing here
that you know what special about earth
to us is that that's our home that's
where we find ourselves and what's
special about our box in math space is
that that's where we find ourselves but
the other ones
are just as real in the sense that if
there's anyone home
there with this subconscious experience
they're going to feel that they're in a
real world
and and if that's true right then
suddenly there's no fire breathing
required anymore and no longer need any
distinction between physical existence
and mathematical existence there's just
the same right distance and if the
mathematical structure exists then the
only question is
what properties does it have are the
properties
complex enough that
there's actually life there and
consciousness or not
so i certainly agree
that
by having this vision that all the
mathematics
exists the same that it's on the equal
footing and we just happen to live in
one of the boxes and there are other by
that certainly gets rid
of this issue of picking out
the one mathematical structure that we
are
familiar with and this is a technique
that we've seen used in the past when i
was an undergraduate i i took philosophy
from robert nozick i think you're you're
familiar with some of his ideas i
remember well at the candidate yeah yeah
right exactly because i was like the
only kid in the freshman physics class
that went to his office hour right so
i'd sit there and and we talk about
things and he would say like what are
you interested as a unified theory i
didn't know what i was talking about as
a freshman i want to do unification and
all these kind of things gravity and so
forth and he said to me so let's say
you're successful and you guys figure
out the unified theory you'll still be
faced with the question why that theory
and not some other theory and so he said
to me the only way that he could imagine
addressing that was as you mentioned
this principle of fecundity where all of
these possible explanations are real and
out there they're just out there in
other universes so so i get the
philosophical move and the power of
obviating the issue of picking one from
the many by saying that many are all out
there but i guess i would say and it
comes back to how we were talking about
things earlier
you described that as coming and i i
know that you're genuine about this
coming from a place of humility just
saying you know it's just one of many
i would just turn it around i just put
it out there that to me
when you think about mathematics as i
was saying early on as the output of
this long series of evolutionary
developments that start with insensate
particles in the universe that gain the
capacity to think and then these
particles come up with natural language
and mathematics for those particle
collections to then say i'm now going to
take all the mathematics that came in
here and assume it's real out there to
me it's kind of the diametrically
opposite view of humility it's like we
have this idea and this way of
describing the world and now everything
i see you know yeah i i can see where
you're where you're coming from there
there
but but we don't have to judge things
based on humility i mean i'm not saying
it's an important one though i mean
first of all i would say regardless of
whether this mathematical universe
hypothesis that i'm pushing is true or
not
i think it's useful if there's a
spectrum of stances you can take
to look not just in the middle but to
actually explore the two extreme ends
also
to intellectually see
what the strengths and weaknesses are uh
um that
i i i obviously i'm not trying to be
humble also i don't
i like to make bets and i'm not gonna
put a hundred percent of my money on on
this being true even though i put a lot
of it
the second thing i think is worth
emphasizing
and coming back again to humility here i
think
this
willingness to um
accept the possibility that reality is
much bigger than we thought is a humble
idea yeah right
right i think the copernican idea that
everything doesn't center around us is
fundamentally humble and i
suspect that some of the resistance
you see to people talking about even
parallel universes are the first kind
never mind this this crazy fourth kind
i'm pushing uh are kind of incensed by
the fact that they feel it it
makes us humans smaller in the grand
scheme of things
and that's something i think we should
just need to let go of you know i agree
i bring that complete vanity get in the
way of seeing the truth and yeah there's
no doubt about that and
and um
then
let's see if i can articulate your
source of unease why you feel it sounds
a little bit heristic it feels like
you're saying that it's hubristic to
assume
that something that we have
started to get glimmers of
through this messy evolutionary process
certainly would be like the perfect
description of everything right so of
course we need to be humble about that
then i know you'll be the first to to
concede that you don't know for sure the
string theory is correct even though i
would go beyond that even you know it's
a separate conversation but i'm not
yeah a proponent of string theory i i'm
interested in its possibilities i don't
think i don't know that it's right by
any means but but stephen weinberg had a
really interesting uh counterpoint to
that actually where he says that the
biggest mistakes theoretical physicists
make is not that they
right or some arrogant that they take
themselves too seriously but they don't
take themselves seriously
yeah no there's an interesting view i
remember reading that and having
conversations with him about that yeah
and just to give you my take on this you
know would he have gone as far as you
though i i'm not gonna i doubt it i
don't take that to mean that we should
be full of ourselves and assume that
we're right yeah which
what i mean is uh that when nature gives
us some very strong hints sometimes uh
which where it seems like our methods
are working unreasonably well yeah it's
a mistake to refuse to follow that
evidence where it leads and we look how
we've
screwed that up big time again and again
right
from from aristotle's silly theory of
motion to newton we spent over a
thousand years where people
were just refusing to take seriously the
idea that
maybe we should just maybe the laws of
gravity that
archimedes and others understood on
earth actually applied in the sky you
know right
and then gamma had to redo the whole
thing for the big bang because people
weren't taking seriously the idea that
maybe the the laws we had discovered of
plasma physics and nuclear physics and
generally could actually be taken back
to the first second after a big bang
um had they tried
you know
they would have seen wow you know it
really works and and here i think we
have a situation which is very analogous
we've seen for the last hundreds of
years again and again and again nature
giving us all these hints
oh now this is also described by math
colors are described by math oh my
goodness even atoms intelligence to
describe a map it would be a mistake to
just
keep us missing this and i agree but but
all of that could also one could say
it's been pointing toward the hours of
explanation been pointing toward a kind
of unique mathematical structure that we
don't have yet none of that has the
outward spreading mathematical hours
saying that all of the mathematics is
relevant to reality it's all pointing
ever more tightly toward one
mathematical structure not all matter i
think you're being unfair to yourself
actually brian because you have done
more than most people and shifting it
from one to all you know in your in your
awesome work on string theory
where where you know
thanks to string theory and people like
alan guth and andre linde we've kind of
requested
one theory realized that actually
there's probably this huge diversity of
stuff diversity like in inflationary
cosmology or string theory is all under
the umbrella of a single mathematical
structure so in inflationary cosmology
we don't have the equations yet but
imagine they were you know so it's
einstein's general relativity some
scalar field but it's one mathematical
structure that gives rise to the many
universes
i don't know anything that points toward
many distinct mathematical structures
all being equally relevant to what we
call reality that's the part that i
don't see any evidence for mm-hmm
there's maybe one piece of evidence
there we could we could talk about but
even without you going there i think
wouldn't you agree with me that the
trend has been though
away from the one and more towards
towards the many like for example when
uh i remember when we celebrated uh
andre linda's 50th birthday i sat next
to ed whit and then he and i had had
some wine and we were he told me about
how he had sort of shifted his
his
betting pool away from the one
to the many we have these numbers we
measure really accurately like the fact
that the proton is 1836 times heavier
than the electron and back when i first
met ed whitton he was hoping we could
compute that number yes just on pencil
and paper
and then at that point he was like nah
no
it's probably just some sort of
multiverse thing and there's diversity
and i think it's too quick to say that
we've gone from the one to the many and
therefore that paradigm that template
applies to mathematical structures agree
to say i i that's not the argument i'm
making i'm just saying that yeah i agree
that no no i i would agree with the the
the the tendency
for people to take the possibility of
other universes more seriously today
than than before i would certainly
need that point but then pushing it to
the place that we're talking about
that's a move that i don't see evidence
for but let me change gears for if
unless you have something you want
because
i just think that the
the historical trend is is one of
greater humility i think we you can ask
what's so special about the number of
eights you know why there are eight
planets in our solar system that would
have seemed like very little nine a
while ago yeah and then
neil degrasse tyson took up take us down
to eight by
demoting pluto but you know how can we
predict eight from string theory
nowadays it sounds ridiculous but it
didn't seem ridiculous kepler you've
seen probably seen his very cute model
where he tries to pick radii of the
planets by putting platonic solids
yeah and now we're like
no
misguided i agree that those numbers
and the radii of those orbits don't tell
us anything about reality they tell us
about our address in reality they tell
us that we're in this solar system i
agree that one and now it seems like
1836
the proton electron mass ratio is also
probably just part of our zip code it
could be an environmental quality as
opposed to a fundamental number in the
world and and i agree that that's an
interesting perspective and you're right
from a string theory or in cosmology
perspective there are trajectories that
naturally lead us to us i don't see the
trajectories that take us
from that to the fecundity of
mathematical structures but anyway the
point that i did want to make or have
you get your view on
where does girdle
fit into this so if we are giving
mathematics this this place of of
reality and primacy girdle comes along
and perhaps just bring the audience i'm
sure most of the folks who are listening
to us are familiar with girdles ideas
but speaks to a certain kind of
incompleteness of these ideas
maybe give us a moment on that and then
say does that have any impact on this
perspective
yeah so this is a fascinating questions
so
girdle came along and and threw a big
monkey wrench into this quest to map out
all those boxes of mathematical
structures right because hilbert had
said well
existence is freedom from contradiction
and he wanted to be able to prove for
each mathematical structure whether it
was consistent or not
and then journal came along and said
look you can't even take the integers
with number theory and prove whether
it's consistent or not you cannot prove
that you can't prove that
two plus two is five and this is really
really really shocking
so
that means that for mathematicians
they have to be very careful when they
start talking about what actually exists
mathematically
for us though for this conversation i
feel this is actually a pretty big red
herring because
what what journal keeps talking about is
that we humans cannot prove
that things are consistent
if our universe could talk to us it
would probably be like who cares uh uh
whether you humans can prove that that i
the universe i'm consistent or not you
know our universe seems to be doing just
fine without us it did fine without us
for 13.8 billion years right
and if we can't prove exactly all sorts
of things about it
it's not the universe's
problem
so but um
does that not
suggest to you
that
um
thinking of all mathematical structures
might be too big a landscape and that it
should be curtailed
to
systems
in which we can answer the kinds of
questions that in these other systems
would be on the reach due to girdles
insights
yeah so this is actually a fascinating
controversy not really involving our
topic about whether our universe is
mathematical but within math itself you
know but some people think that even
though politicians
have these very spirited debates against
each other mathematicians all
agree on all the foundations and that
that is really not true right there has
been this very spirited debate
for over 100 years about
what should actually count as
mathematical existence and where people
get queasy in math is where infinity
comes in you know the famous uh leopold
chroniclers once said that you know
god created the integers all else is the
work of man yes exactly because he
really didn't like the business with
real numbers with infinitely many
decimal places
computer scientists don't like them so
much either because you can't store even
one such number in your computer because
you need infinitely much memory and
and uh so i sometimes wonder you know
i'm gonna be teaching uh freshman
physics starting next week again
and i'm gonna be doing integrals and all
these things where i'm telling the
students
that
infinity is real and and the position
the distance between two points
actually is meaningful to infinitely
many decimal places but in my heart of
hearts do i really believe that that's
how the world is no i don't actually i i
take very seriously what what you and
others have said about quantum gravity
that
beyond the fourth the 34th decimal place
distances probably don't make sense
and that is probably just a really
useful approximation much like
it's much easier to figure out the sound
that makes you hear me now if you treat
the air as just the continuum
where no matter how much you zoom in
it's just smooth with a density and a
pressure the truth is no it's a bunch of
atoms which are very much finite uh but
which is easier assuming infinity
is easier so we do that i wouldn't be
too shocked actually in the future if it
turns out that um
you know maybe when one of your grad
students grad students discovers the
theory of everything hey or maybe you
will leave it
if it turns out to actually get rid of
infinity in a big way
uh with
with our current understanding there's
some there is at least
something curious that might be worth
pointing out i mean
we discussed we started by talking about
the electron you know minus one and a
half you know the quarks you know
two-thirds
so the very theory that we currently
have yeah that does involve
you know the issues that we're raising
so the very
theory that's our best guess yeah
provisional guess kind of stands
outside this notion of not involving the
things that would run afoul of a of a
girdle kind of blockage incompleteness
does that
concern you or you just say hey that's
just provisional we're on we're enroute
toward the final theory whatever it may
be and when we have that
it will not suffer from these issues
yeah that might this is just a wild
guess actually but i'm happy i would be
happy to make a wager that
if we do discover what you what you will
sign off on as a
as the theory of quantum gravity in our
lifetime that it will not involve
any of the girdling completeness issues
you know it's pretty it pretty
interesting hint i think that all the
engineers and scientists who simulate
our universe
always manage to do that just fine on
their super computers with finite number
of bits
right and whereas
even if you're going to sneak a single
real number in there it has infinitely
many decimals and infinite bits you
couldn't even input it into the computer
let alone do anything with it so if if
we can actually do all the
computations
with finite
you know
who's to say that nature can't also
right right yeah no no i i
i think fundamentally there's a
resonance of that view with my own
uh
even though um again coming back to
unique mathematics versus plurality of
mathematics i think it's all pointing
perhaps toward the uniqueness at least
in our observable universe let me if you
don't mind a few questions come in from
uh the audience and and and
just uh just to make it a little
interactive um yeah
it might make a dark confession to me
yeah right between your audience and a
faculty meeting here and uh if you
promised not to tell my faculty
colleagues i prefer talking to your
audience
yeah good good good we will uh keep that
just between us folks right here
um so and we also have this program
world science scholars where we have
kids from around the world who
have exceptional mathematical talent who
have an interesting program that we
create from them a couple of those
scholars have some questions so ahmed
ali from qatar asks over the past few
centuries it looks like the laws of
physics have become more complex for
example newton's three laws of motion
and the inverse square law seem more
fundamental and more obviously part of a
reality than the collection of you know
tens and dozens of particles complicated
forces long equations that exist today
the standard model and so forth so would
you number one say that the laws of
physics have become more complex and can
you extrapolate from that
to where you think things are going
oh that's a great question i actually
think it's been going kind of on a
sawtooth pattern like
like more and more complex than poof
simpler and then more and more complex
and then simpler and more and more
complex and simpler let's take a
concrete example of this
so
you know first there were just the four
elements
earth wind fire and air right
and then it got more complex actually no
that's not quite enough you actually
need carbon and oxygen and nitrogen and
by the time people were up to you know
many many dozens of elements people like
man what a mess then mendeleev comes
along puts it all in a periodic table
and then
suddenly we got this fast simplification
when it turns out there are only three
things you need
you don't need the hundred atoms you
just need
protons neutrons and electrons great you
know so suddenly
simplification
then it got worse again then we started
discovering well there's also other
particles you know what about the k ons
and the phi psi and the sigma particle
and this and that and that
and then another unification
people realize actually these are all
made of quarks and they're actually just
six quarks and three leptons and and so
on
and maybe they are all made of
ultimately a vibrating super strings or
something like this uh so it seems to me
like what the periods when things seem
to be getting more complicated it's kind
of
that experimentalists are pulling ahead
of the theorists piling on more and more
evidence that we haven't yet managed to
fully make sense of and then comes this
click you know when the theorists catch
up and realize that actually there's
this new hidden simplicity where all
falls into place again and
and um
i'm not i'm curious what you think
actually do you think there's going to
be a final click or where we get some
theory
where there's some ultimate theory which
is actually really beautifully simple or
or do you think the ultimate truth is
actually a total mass no i think um if
one means by ultimate theory
the ultimate
description is the way i would describe
it going back to our other conversation
of of the elementary ingredients and the
forces by which they interact then i do
think that there will be a final
articulation of that particular story
but whether that story is as exhaustive
as we want it to be that's a question
mark for me
whether whether
that will be enough at least in
principle or whether we'll find that
somehow
it's not the full story but i do think
when it comes to the ingredients and
their interactions there will be
um a final description and i find that
we physicists and mathematicians are
very good at taking an initial theory
that might look very complicated and
finding a way of expressing it in
simpler language i mean for those of you
who studied maxwell's theory
electromagnetism you know it's often
described as four equations that you've
probably seen a divergence of e rho over
epsilon naught and so forth
and we can now describe it really in
using differential forms as you know two
equations
but if you go back to maxwell's original
papers which i did by the way oh you did
right it's a mess
it's a whole page with six different
variables and for the different
components of the field yeah crazy and
it didn't even have
yeah exactly so so as time goes on we
are pretty good and in fact you know
there's this famous image that i love to
post on twitter now and then but people
use it in all different contexts of the
standard model of particle physics where
every single term in the equation is
written out and with very small type
it's like you know densely packed on a
page but then we can articulate it with
you know a single equation if we're
clever about the notation so and then
it's more than just notation
understanding the symmetries that relate
the various terms allows us to express
them in a more concise framework so so i
do think that ultimately it will be
quite simple whether it's full and and
exhaustive i think
that is another question um and speaking
yeah eugene wigner another hero of mine
had this
interesting
argument also about
how we think about what's simple so i i
have my mathematical universe t-shirt on
to your to honor you today here where
thank you illustrate that things usually
look like most complicated on the human
scale and if you start looking smaller
and smaller
it looks simpler
here is tribute to you brian little
string
in a columbia manifold but also when you
look out on much larger scales you start
to see a lot of simpler things and and
it looks the messiest exactly on our
scale and
and
you know wegner talked about how
traditionally we've taken everything
that we could describe with math and so
that's the simple part it's physics and
everything else we call initial
conditions and we say blame it on the
historians and to say it's not our
department we don't have to explain it
yeah but but on your next show
alan guth and andre linda are going to
tell you that actually they can explain
that because
their inflation just makes all of the
initial conditions somewhere all the
same in some sense
in that sense more
is actually simpler because now the only
thing
that all the complexity is describing is
your address in this big space and and
the very properties of nature are
actually simple yep um one more question
from
the audience i hope i'm pronouncing a
name correctly michael
lipiak from poland
assuming that a world is a mathematical
structure do you think it's possible for
humans to unambiguously determine it or
will it be physically impossible for
some reason
well that's a really really great
question uh
we've in the past
sometimes been in the situation where we
kind of almost thought we had it like
when i showed you that little family
tree of mathematical structures there
was one that was three plus
one-dimensional pseudo-romano manifolds
obeying these certain field equations
einstein was kind of hoping that that
was it
in in 2015 right with general relativity
uh
it was nineteen percent 1915 thank you
yeah and oopsie of course no quantum
mechanics put a stop to that
and um
it um
i try to be very open-minded about
whether we'll ev whether
we'll get to the point where we can
actually
guess one that
is the right one or whether we'll still
be wondering whether
there's this one that fits perfectly all
the evidence but it could also be some
of these other more complicated ones
and the only experiment we can think of
to tell the difference
is so complicated you know we can't do
it in our universe
yeah yeah
there yeah it might yeah
it might also be that in some way we
have yet to fully understand
uh
that maybe simple things it's some
mathematical way exist a little bit more
and have some more weight
if you ask alan and andre about the
measure problem sure a fascinating
discussion about no doubt it will come
up um yeah so me let me turn to one
final topic
um one in which i think
we do uh a line perhaps completely but
it'd be good nice wait face to end kick
it around a little bit so you described
your own trajectory focusing for a long
time on the external world and then
last few years focusing somewhat more on
the the inner world of conscious
experience and of course the big
questioning consciousness so-called hard
problem of consciousness and the
language of david chalmers is
how in the world is it that these
particles that we've been talking about
electrons quarks and so forth that we
don't think have any inner world of
experience themselves how can
collections of them somehow come
together swirl move in the right pattern
execute the right choreography and give
each of us this inner world that
lives inside of our heads
where does that come from how is that
even possible yeah where do you come
down on that question fantastic question
let me say two things first why i'm so
excited about the question and then what
i think about it sure so why am i so
excited about it
if you had uh
a time machine and you could bring
galileo on on this show right he would
tell you that he
could describe beautifully with
mathematics how a grape and a hazelnut
would move if he threw them he could
show you the equation with the parabola
and all of that stuff but he would have
no clue how to explain why the
grape was green and the hazelnut was
brown and why the grape was soft and
squishy
and the hazelnut was really really hard
but then so at that point of galileo
really of all the things you could try
to do with physics
there was very little you could you
could describe motion of things and not
much else right
sin then maxwell came along you
mentioned him and figured out all the
stuff of colors with math and physics
then quantum mechanics explained why the
hazelnut is hard and why the grape is
soft and so on and now we've gone from
physics being able to to handle almost
no natural phenomena to almost all of
them there and what's the final front
here aside from the the very biggest
things in the very tiniest quantum
gravity the the ultimate final frontier
really is what's in here i think
intelligence and consciousness and and
um
many people had for a long time thought
that uh that was gonna be hopeless uh
then our ai then artificial intelligence
researchers
started to show that you could
replicate more and more of what we
considered intelligence also
mathematically in machines
and uh we're still not at the point
where
you have to worry about your job being
replaced by an ai but we have to start
being open to the idea that intelligence
itself is probably
some form of information processing not
any old information processing but some
form and
so it's quarks and electrons you know
moving in very particular patterns
but that is what intelligence is and so
what about consciousness then
many some people mistakenly i think put
an equal sign between intelligence and
consciousness which i think is a huge
mistake
you know there are
obviously things which
are intelligent without being conscious
you your brain does a lot of very
intelligent things that you're quite
unconscious about
from regulating your heartbeat to even
recognizing me when you open your eyes
there you have no idea how you took
those millions of pixels on your screen
and
computed this was maxed you should have
got an email from some unconscious
module of your brain saying you know
image completion image analysis face
recognition task completed infusive
workface area you know here is a result
and then your consciousness module kind
of got that right and so so that shows
right there i think that
consciousness
intelligence doesn't have to be
conscious and what about the other way
around um can you have something which
is conscious without being intelligent i
certainly think so there have been times
when i felt very dumb i was just sort of
sitting gazing out over a beautiful view
i felt very conscious of how beautiful
it was but i couldn't get
any coherent thought through my brain
and
my personal guess
is that the answer to your question
about what consciousness is is that both
consciousness and intelligence
are certain types of information
processing they're not exactly the same
type
and that consciousness is basic is the
way
information feels when being processed
in in certain ways so let me just unpack
that
a little bit here you know
the the amazing thing which is powered
the computer revolution
is the insight
that you can process information
without worrying very much about
what
how exactly the quarks and electrons are
moving around
all that matters is the structure of the
information processing and it doesn't
even matter whether the zeros and ones
are represented by
you know how many
volts there are on a capacitor which
corresponds to how many electrons there
are somewhere or whether it corresponds
instead the
some totally different physical way of
representing it it's the structure at
this higher level only
that matters for how smart something is
right
and i i suspect it's the same with
consciousness that there's some
kinds of some structure of information
processing which
when it takes place
has a subjective experience which which
david chalmers has articulated so well
so you know if if you're driving a car
right
you're experiencing uh
maybe road rage if it's in manhattan
you're certainly experiencing colors and
vibrations and sounds and so on but a
self-driving car
is it subjectively experiencing anything
at all does it feel like anything to be
a self-driving car you know
we don't know but i fundamentally
think that this is a science question we
have been a little bit too lazy to
tackle properly and and uh
my guess is
that it has an answer that there are
some equations maybe that um
if information processing satisfies them
then there's an experience there you
know otherwise there isn't giulio tinoni
has written down some equations he
presented at a conference david chalmers
organized there are others like scott
aronson who think those equations are
wrong yeah but the beautiful thing is
that finally
after thousands of years you know this
question of consciousness has gone from
being speculated about in bars becoming
an actual respect the stable science
topic which i think is a sign of
this final frontier that's resisted the
scientific description you know
at least being a contender now for
something that maybe we can describe now
having mentioned both of us mentioned
david chalmers perhaps it's worth just
asking
he beat his head against the wall for a
very long time starting from uh i
believe he was trained as a physicist
i think so
yeah and ultimately came to the
perspective i i think he probably
started his journey from a place very
similar to the way that you've described
things trying to push that perspective
forward ultimately felt he couldn't do
it and that forced him in his mind to
conclude
that our assumption that particles don't
have any kind of conscious quality is
wrong and that we do need to assign some
kind of proto-consciousness
quality beyond the minus one for
electric charge and the half for the
speed
does that do you think we will be pushed
to do that
i
i'm very i try to be very humble about
this i'm guessing that he's wrong about
that one and i'll explain why but i i i
try to keep an open mind the reason i
think it's not that way is
instead of talking about consciousness
let's talk about the property of wetness
okay yeah so like this water has
definitely has a property of wetness
is it because it's made of
protons and electrons and neutrons that
are wet
no right that makes no sense to talk
about whether a single electron is wet
or not right
wetness is something
is at a higher level it only makes sense
to talk about
in terms of the nature of how the
different particles are interacting with
each other my guess is that
consciousness is very much like that
it's some it's an emergent phenomena
that happens only only exists at the
higher level
you can't talk about whether one you
don't have to be able to talk about
whether one proton is conscious or not
but if you have
10 to the power 27 of them in your brain
you know
and they're doing this elaborate
information processing it may very well
be that
that
is
conscious yeah the one thing i would say
in that i mean i have to say
fundamentally i do have a perspective
that is pretty much in alignment with
yours but just to be fair you know david
would say and i know this because i've
had the conversation with him that sure
when it comes to wetness that's a
collective phenomenon of the particles
but in principle you could determine
that objective third-party quality from
our understanding of the objective
third-party qualities of electric charge
and spin and so forth but he would say
when it comes to consciousness because
it is fundamentally distinct it's not an
objective third-party quality it's an
inner first person subjective quality he
just doesn't see any way that that could
emerge from particles that themselves
don't have any of those subjective first
person qualities themselves but anyway
yeah don't get me wrong i i'm
absolutely not claiming to know the
answer
to this right and it's in fact
my my favorite question to lose sleep
over
what it why is it that you can put
together a big blob of quarks and
electrons and it's going to feel like
something to be them yep yeah i think
not only is it fascinating but it's like
the most important question of our time
as we start building ai because
meaning and purpose
are all they're
they're emotions their subjective
experiences right if we try to create a
good world rather than a bad world where
you want to eliminate suffering
suffering is a subjective experience
right yeah we can't just be talking
about oh our goal is to have a universe
where the electrons are moving this way
rather than that way that's not why
you're against torture you're against
torture because there's a negative
subjective experience there so if we
have no clue
what it mean what it is that causes
subjective experience
how can we be sure that if we build very
advanced ai systems
that we can talk with and interact with
and and like spread into our universe
and do all sorts of cool stuff how can
we be so sure that they're not going to
suffer or or that they're just going to
be some kind of zombies
which are going through the motions and
don't experience anything that would be
the ultimate zombie apocalypse if if
what we maybe one day
think of as our descendants or something
if they don't experience anything and
then the universe just goes back to be
dead i'd much rather that david chalmers
and and others figure out
what
quirk blobs are conscious and what
aren't then when you get your home
helper robot in the future you know to
help you through
you and tracy through retirement
you maybe have a little switch maybe you
can put it in unconscious mode when you
wanted to take out the trash and do
boring stuff
and you can how kind so you don't have
to feel guilty about that then and turn
into consciousness and erase those
memories before our consciousness turn
back on the first thing you do is
understand at least what this is but in
all seriousness do you think that there
is any fundamental
obstacle
toward an artificial system having an
inner world of conscious experience
no
i i i think the whole
distinction between artificial and not
it just means whether we figure out how
to build it yet or not a robot is made
of exactly the same kind of quirks and
electrons that you are right and i know
you don't believe that
your ability to do string theory or
fall in love with tracy is specifically
because you're made of carbon atoms as
opposed to some other kind of atoms
right as far as i know no other
collection of atoms has fallen in love
with tracy yet so as an experimental
question but uh i absolutely agree with
you i i too
don't see any fundamental obstacle to
all of the inner experiences that we
have
being experienced by a system that
happens to be constructed in a different
way from how human beings are currently
constructed which i think is just a
feature of how evolution has gotten us
to this point but as we go to the future
that need not be the only way that these
kinds of common collections of particles
are constructed i'm so glad brian that
you're not a carbon chauvinist because i
do have some colleagues i respect
greatly who just take that as an axiom
like of course
nothing else can be conscious if it's
not biologically evolved and i i think
that's an
assumption that there really isn't very
much scientific basis for the other
scary uh attitude i often see is that
this is all this bs talking about
consciousness we shouldn't talk about it
but then in that case we should also
stop talking about torture and we should
stop saying that we're against it you
know i've never met anybody who can
explain to me
what's so bad about torture
without invoking the idea of subjective
experience yeah and
for me
as scientists you know
no matter how much we'd like to geek out
about equations we should never forget
our humanity they were ultimately trying
to do good things
and and all of our notions of of what's
good and what's not good
hinge on
consciousness on subjective experience
and how can we possibly say with a
straight face that we're trying to make
the world better if we refuse to talk
about
consciousness refuse to talk about what
good means yeah no and i fully agree and
i think both of us are are pleased
and tell me if you feel different but i
can't imagine you do with the fact that
there was a time
when scientists couldn't talk about
consciousness in a serious way without
being ostracized it was the topic that
you only spoke about when you were too
old to do real thinking about real
science
and now it's come to a place where it's
respectable to begin to talk about these
ideas we all agree that we are in the
infancy
of understanding consciences but as you
say you know coke and chanoni and others
are even trying to put mathematical
might behind these early ideas of what
consciousness might be and i think
that's
a very positive development for science
and for humanity going forward
yeah i couldn't agree more and you know
there's a lot of historical precedence
to this so
people
you have to be as you know if you are a
scientist right then you are very well
aware that
that the boundary between what's
considered science right now and what's
not
is um not an immutable boundary it keeps
shifting right
there was a time when when people were
pretty serious about ghosts
right and now that's considered utterly
unscientific and and there are a lot of
other things which once upon a time also
people thought was maybe scientific and
now you sort of just uh
smile when you hear about it and then
technology and things like that yeah and
then there are other things which have
gone the other way i actually
geeked out on this uh your question of
yours to the point
that i actually
drew a picture of of it as well if i can
we can just put this super briefly on
the yeah on the screen here
let's see
do you see my um i do i think i see it i
don't know if the audience is seeing it
i assume are yep they are yeah so
you know
witchcraft and ghosts and psychokinesis
and
telepathy and so on they have left uh
mainstream science and other things came
in instead like
you know einstein was very dissed
when he came up with a relativity theory
some of the
nazis in charge said this was jewish
physics and
bad stuff
dark matter was considered very flaky
black holes were considered very
speculative and now they're considered
mainstream science parallel universes
right now is just kind of on the verge
there
yeah plate tectonics used to be this
right and
in math there were also things which
used to be considered very irrespective
but even people who started talking
about irrational numbers or imaginary
numbers were often criticized at the
time and now can you imagine walking
into calculus class at
columbia and claiming that
it's not science to talk about complex
numbers i mean
things change and
consciousness i think is exactly one of
those questions one of those topics
which is coming in is just in the
process of coming in to the mainstream
of science yep
and welcome i totally agree so max it's
been a it's been a fascinating
conversation thanks thanks for joining
us and let me just
end by encouraging everyone who's
watching to number one check out
max's book or any of max's books but
we've been focusing on ideas that he
developed in our mathematical
universe but he has a wonderful book on
the future of life and and and
intelligent thought which is called uh
life 3.0 is that the correct title great
so you should check those out and also
you should look at the program of the
world science festival that we posted
two weeks ago max was part of that
conversation as was david albert shelly
goldstein and sylvia jonas
on a more broad conversation about does
math reveal reality you can find that on
the world science festival website and
finally i'll just uh encourage you to
keep your eyes out for
the next program which will be in about
two weeks a program on language i
mentioned this at the outset with noam
chomsky stephen pinker evelyn federenko
and daniel dorr and again if any of you
have the killer title for that program
on language and thought send it to us
we'd be uh happy to use it happy to
credit you we haven't really come up
with the right title yet and then uh in
steady state we hope to have these
conversations and those
more produced formal programs in our
virtual theater on average every week
but we're starting every other week as
we gear up our production in this
unfortunately persisting coveted world
maybe next june we'll have a live world
science festival in new york there will
be i think a live world science festival
they're claiming in brisbane australia
for those of you in that part of the
world in march unfortunately i won't be
able to go nobody from here will
australia apparently is not going to
open its borders until post that date
but we will stay in touch with you
through these online programs and our
virtual
conversations in our virtual theater as
those will be coming on a regular basis
all right that's all from us here again
thank you max for joining us and
guys uh in in two weeks with our program
on
language okay
thank you thank you to the awesome
viewer questions from around the world
as far as poland and thank you brian for
this absolutely fascinating conversation
i really enjoyed it my pleasure thank
you for joining us okay folks signing
off here from world science festival
headquarters in new york city